hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to monstrum now we have
a plan things did not go very well for
us in the last episode not my fault at
all not even close to my fault you may
think it was my fault but it was this
damn cursed ship that dust hold my soul
hostage and present itself to the
monster oh I found the beer kegs perfect
how those alien bastards won't get him
them from me I suppose is somehow
supposed to make me feel better I'm a
horrible horrible life out of old oh I
don't like this game my least favorite
game to play okay there's a whole lot of
nothing everybody celebrate nothing bad
happens
now we've got a plan of attack and we're
not gonna flan around and died a
horrible monstrosity
not the world away this time anyway hey
who put all this poop in my pants I'm
not lucky enough to get exactly what I
need right here
I got a flare set a flare again why do I
need a flare gun you better back off big
right I'm a security guard with a flare
gun
I'm on the edge I'm uncontrollable
they're gonna know that did nothing oh
then how about this I got up oh you're
on yeah yeah oh you don't like that oh
hey guess what cameraman I'm a giant
idiot a big dumb douchebag why don't you
go meat to meat red/blue eBay's already
having rip me a new one
[Applause]
[Music]